another day and another set of covid19
rules
laid out by the government this time for
the people of the northeast
boris johnson says extra restrictions
are needed here
but the prime minister got into a bit of
a muddle when asked to explain
what his new laws actually were in the
northeast
or in other areas where extra tight
measures have been brought in you should
follow the guidance of
of of local authorities
but it's it's it's six in in in a home
or six in
in hospitality but uh as i understand it
not six outside
what he meant to say was that the new
guidelines for the north
east banned people from mixing with
others outside their household or social
bubble
in indoor settings and that includes
pubs and restaurants
i'm going to show you this clip in
newcastle we showed shoppers what the pm
had said
and there was general confusion about
what any of it meant
i was messaging family and friends
yesterday what can we do what
can we not do and nobody kind of oh i
didn't know that
really you know very good the prime
minister's words cleared that up for you
no
if he's going to tell the rules
obviously you need to understand them
for everyone else to understand
everyone's a bit muddled up with
everything that's going on so some
people wear masks some people aren't
it's causing a lot of ruggers in the
country the prime minister has since
apologized
but his mistake came only a few hours
after one of his ministers
admitted not knowing the details when
asked the same question
on the radio boris johnson's critics say
all of this has seriously undermined
faith in the governments
the fact that the prime minister himself
doesn't know what they mean
doesn't feel anybody with any confidence
that the rest of government knows what
it's doing either
so new rules are coming into force for
the north east on top of restrictions
already in place but
as we've been finding out there is
widespread confusion which is going to
have an
impact when it comes to compliance and
as for bars and restaurants well
they say the new measures will have a
devastating impact
on their businesses well i look forward
to seeing it
who owns several coffee shops bars and
restaurants
despairs at the government's handling of
the crisis and fears for the future
for my business um it means i don't
believe we are
able to trade under those tighter
restrictions still
and so we've taken the opportunity with
furlough still being in place
to put all our staff back on further
nearly 200 people
and close all our sights again and
go back to go back to day one sadly
there is no doubt the restrictions are
becoming more complicated and difficult
to follow
but the government says unless there's
evidence the tide is turning
they'll likely stay in place for the
next six months
alex rossi sky news newcastle